here are five more cosmic disasters that  could destroy the world a massive  gamma-ray burst hits the earth a  gamma-ray burst is one of the most  electromagnetic events in the universe  if one hit earth it would bring lethal  doses of radiation a rogue star enters  our solar system if a visiting sun  entered our solar system the moons and  planets it brings along with it could  smash into earth sending our world into  the depths of space a rogue planet  enters our solar system if a rogue  planet hit earth it could eject the  planet from the solar system the earth's  core cools down this would destroy the  earth's magnetic field causing the  atmosphere to become similar to mars a  massive solar storm hits the earth a  powerful enough solar storm could  destroy all our satellites and power  grids leaving us with no electricity or  technology essentially sending us back  to the stone age so